how's of guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to episode 13 of the Sparky game
engine series so last time we created a
transformation stack in our renderers so
in case you guys missed what that
awesomeness was about it was all about
this transformation stack and having the
ability to basically push a matrix to
the renderer and have it render all of
its components all of its variables with
that matrix in mind so that we could
apply basically a bunch of rotations to
a group of objects now all this stuff is
good right having having having having
this this transformation matrix is
fantastic but it's kind of not really
useful unless you've got groups so we're
going to talk about groups so last times
what we had last time we had a bunch of
matrix operations and we talked about
how the transformation stack is going to
work today we're going to talk about
groups so what are groups well groups
are very very simple groups are simply
groups of round ripples so instead of us
having a normal renderable which just
has everything it has inside it it's got
you know it's got it it's got everything
that we need to render it as we know in
in our case it's got a position a size
it's got all that stuff a group is a
renderable right it's just that a group
has a vector of its own renderable z--
so these are these two notes also be
known as children okay so a group has a
bunch of children now that is really it
right the only other thing the group has
which is kind of important is a group
has a transformation matrix for its
children so it will have some kind of
matrix okay it'll have some kind of
matrix okay that's really the only way
it differs from a runner ball it has
these two extra features it's got a
vector and a mat for now the question
that will probably come up is how do we
actually render groups right and what
happens to the size in the position and
all that stuff everything gets stored in
a mat for that's totally okay when we
create a group we just create a group
and we add all this stuff to it it's
around herbal that's all we need to know
about it
but it it does become a bit different
okay so if we go out over here I'm just
going to under layers I'm going to
create a new item called Group H okay
pragma once pass steal our namespace
will have a renderable so I mean we have
to have that because renderable so a
class group public renderable 2d so it
has as I mentioned a vector of
renderable two days okay
so I'll call this M R and ervil's and it
has a matrix called transformation
matrix alright that's it other than that
is pretty much identical now the other
thing we have to realize is the groups
groups traditionally do not actually
have positions right so if we look at
renderable to day and whatnot we see
that we have position size color these
are not things that a group has there
okay a group doesn't have those things a
group instead has bunch of children so
what I'm saying is that groups
themselves do not actually get rendered
right groups do not get drawn groups
children get drawn not the actual group
itself though which is basically making
me almost rethink my whole design of
having all of these things right all of
these positions and my goodness here we
go
position size in color right what that's
okay that's a chapter for another day we
might talk about that in maintenance and
whatnot but now right now it's totally
okay so what needs to happen though is
we need to adjust as renderable to
basically have something called you
might want to call it like submit
something or Randa you can call it
render as well but what this will do
what is void and it will definitely be
virtual and it will definitely be okay
so will will refer at this minute it
yeah it probably won't be pure we'll
just go around so it takes in a renderer
let me quickly include that we might not
be able to actually so ignore that
okay so takes in a renderer and what it
will do is it'll hit up renderer dot so
by default if we don't override it it
should just go something like a renderer
adults submit this okay that's what it
should do so which is it
it should submit the current renderable
to the renderer okay I doubt we'll be
able to include the renderer though
because of the fact that a renderer also
includes and renderable so what we could
do is just declare it as a class like
this and then in the C++ file which we
don't have so inside bash renderer will
include renderable same with the simple
renderer
okay that way we avoid recursive
inclusion where we include each other so
we can't have a renderer include
renderable and renderable include
renderer because that way well it's just
like an infinite loop right okay cool
so anyway at that aside where are we in
okay we should probably do this in here
okay anyway now that we've done that we
should go into our renderable and now
that we've got renderer 2d yeah that's
really all it's going to do okay it's
gonna be virtual though we can totally
override it and we probably will so now
that we've got this we should go into
our group it does do that and it will
actually override the submit that we
have apps
okay so it'll be overriding everything
and what it will do is a little bit
differently than what at the default
invitation dollars which just basically
submits it so one thing I should imagine
is that in our actual layer when we do
this stuff this is what kind of changes
right because now we don't call render
adult submit for it ran durable we
actually call renderable dot submit with
the renderer okay we will call end and
begin on the leather that's really
important as well we don't want to be
calling that every time or whatever that
will still happen on the latter but the
submission will happen like this so we
basically just reversed it a bit which
is pretty cool but now the renderable is
actually in charge of how it gets
submitted not the layer which is an
important distinguish and an important
distinction as well with how the system
will work so if we add the group dot cpp
files but we can actually implement
everything now let's see so we've got
our
include Group H construction will most
likely do nothing fact I'd I constructor
but it will probably do nothing yes
so one thing we have to do for our
renderable is actually create a
protected default constructor which is
basically does nothing okay so this is
protected those we won't be able to use
it anywhere else but we basically not
don't set position size and color
because we don't need to so out here in
in group we've got this now so that does
nothing I could have told you about her
in the header but submit is where all
the fun stuff happens because this will
this submit all that is obviously going
to be a bit different then then the
submit in our normal thing okay which
was in I'm terrible at some classes but
in here okay cool so this is what we had
been almost submit and all of it was
submit this this is going to do it this
is going to do something very different
it's not gorgeous a bit itself instead
it's actually going to go through
everything and submit everything so if
we go for basically each renderable 2d
that we have renderable in M ran
durables or M children or whatever you
want to call it will basically just go
ahead and say renderable dot submit so
we're just calling submit on it right
and we submitted it with the renderer
and the renderer of course at this thing
okay
one more thing we need to do though
obviously to include all this
transformation stack is use the
transformation matrix we have here and
actually basically push it to the render
as stack so push
that and then pop okay so that's how it
works again it's really simple and it's
pretty straightforward but that is how
submit works and that is pretty much the
story of groups okay we could have
called this children or something em
children or something I just called
render Bulls to keep it on a more
generic but that's the idea so now let's
test out groups and make sure
everything's working so if I include
source graphics players group we tried
to make our button thing last time that
didn't really work out obviously because
we hadn't what wasn't supposed to work
out okay we're getting a lot of problems
what's up this sounds like regressive
inclusion or something I pretty sure
I've avoided that there okay
sorry buffer is an undeclared identifier
I'm sure of including that because
renderable probably includes that as
well I should be fine um and in batch
renderer we've got so we include the
renderer and that's it so we don't
include whatever and Drupal where's that
included in vulnerable are the renderer
includes that okay so the renderer
includes the rent has the renderable
okay so that's the renderer the renderer
includes it doesn't include vulnerable
that does we don't need the
implementation of that though I'm pretty
sure I hate tracing these things it's a
bit annoying and it takes a bit of time
so that's fine
okay well let's include the vector that
should get rid of some of the problems I
believe or not alright to get rid of
some of them okay so okay so saying M
buffer isn't cleared and buffer easing
battery under there so what does
renderable do so renderable includes
renderer
what we got rid of that I think that
would help
no includes a pretty messy renderable TD
so we do need that Oh Gomez yes so
renderable today does didn't just have
that it also had a vertex data so we
need to make sure we do that as well I'd
much rather do it the other way around
ah yeah here's what we'll do we'll cut
this out completely we'll go into Bosch
renderer we will include renderable 3d
which will screw everything up as you'll
see in a minute we'll build that we'll
see it fail or succeed either way is
fine and if we go into
yeah so that's totally okay because
because of the implementations so that's
that's alright but here we go that was
our last thing right we had this problem
where well we didn't have a problem but
we basically wanted this to be relative
to that we wanted it to be inside it so
what we can do is we can basically we
can basically have a group right and we
can add this button to the group so if
you check if you take a look at this
later Add button we had all that stuff
so what we can do is we can make a group
okay one thing we definitely need to do
though is somehow set this
transformation stack so we probably want
to I don't know we probably want to have
some kind of like yeah well taking a
matrix probably I kind of do like I
don't want to do that though mmm yeah so
I guess we'll just take in constant at
four
transform
okay sir yes all right so that's the
plan that's how we get it to be so what
we do need to do is when we create the
group we give it the transform of say
this which is kind of what we wanted it
to be so we push in a mass for
translation say minus 15 five zero
okay it's out is our matrix now then
what we do is we add this button to the
group at zero zero now because it's
relative to the beginning of the group
right and I guess there's we need to
have the add method and then finally we
add this to the we had this Brian which
is relative the other one to the group
as well and then we go ahead and we add
the group delay oh okay so that makes
sense hopefully it does yes so let's
create this group on the heap all right
and then let's make the add method for
group so avoid add renderable to d
renderable yes
so inside group
so M ma R intervals dot pushback for
interval okay cool so there we go
there's my arrows so if we just take a
look at this the button should now be
inside as you can see this thing now
what if we want something inside this so
what if you want a group of groups is
that possible of course it is so what we
can do is if we wanted that to be group
we could create a new group or in fact
just be like group add new group
actually we would have to make it a new
group so we could have a third group
let's just say so that's that's that
group and then we have a button which is
a new group at say
let's just say what was it point five
point five zero we don't need these
maths
okay so we have the new group that is
the button in here so we add the button
it doesn't matter how you do this by the
way it doesn't matter the order that you
do this in but we have this which we
basically add into this group so we add
it into the button
it was very slight getting complicated
but nice
so just zero zero and then if suddenly I
want text inside that button for example
offset by a bit I can add a new sprite
that might be it like 0.5 0.5 relative
to that and with a width and height of
like 3-1 or something it doesn't really
matter and we'll make it like white no
if we already had white we'll make it
like blue all in fact we'll just make it
like a nice blue my favorite blue that's
alright a lot of stuff going on but
there you go so now you can see that's
relative to that that's right about that
everything's nice with each other
everything looks good now the cool thing
is again we could say our matrix is just
a translation matrix we could actually
say make it a rotation matrix so we
could rotate it by 45 degrees on the z
axis and multiply it with our
translation
I keep forgetting that we don't need
mouths yeah and you should see that
everything is totally as you can see
translated correctly okay and we
probably should have done it the other
way around by the way all right right so
we can see that it's everything gets
real a guest around I get ready to get
rotated relative to each other
and if we wanted the other one to be
irritated the other way I don't get I
don't know why but if you wanted that to
be the case you could be like I want
this new group to this yes I want this
new group for example to be not only
offset like that but rotated another 45
degrees or whatever right and then you
can see that I probably just you to call
them negative 90 and now you can see
well you can see how that's just rotated
now as well and of course I should have
done it the other way around
all right there we go so you can do some
pretty crazy stuff like that let's take
it back to what it was before though
because that was much simpler for people
to understand I bet but I think general
generally it should be pretty good so
that's pretty much gonna wrap up this
episode wait what am i okay so we had we
had the transformation matrix just being
I think like okay let's just go do that
all right
never yeah cool so that is how groups
work it's pretty cool it's pretty simple
if you guys enjoy this episode please
hit like button next time we're going to
take a look at loading in images and
then continue on so if you guys enjoy
this episode please hit the like button
I'll see you guys next time goodbye